the sounds of War only a few people are
left in this border
Village the pictures of commanders now
dead give Testament to previous Wars
here Maher is a retired military officer
and has witnessed several conflicts he
says he has many reasons to
stay this is my land I was born here I
won't leave it whatever happens I lived
through many wars my family is in Beirut
but I'm not
leaving Fahad is 80 years old she lives
with her husband who's
unwell she says they don't have the
energy to
leave where am I to go my sick husband
is inside our home with me along the 120
km of border between Lebanon and Israel
there is nowhere for people to take
proper shelter in an attack and no
warning sirens
what government do we have there is none
they only know how to loot the country
we are left alone as
always much like the few people left
here these sheep make use of the fleet
in moments they get each day to venture
out and find food between one exchange
of fire and another a tend scal that
allows people left in the Border towns
to move around but then the sound of
drones breaks the silence a signal of
another round of bombing powerless in
the center of an unpredictable conflict
people here can only hope it will end
soon Ali Hashim Al jaaz South
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer